10 things you need to know about Sundar Pichai a
is Google's new CEO Sundar Pichai has been named CEO
of Google by the company's founders Larry Page and sergey
brin
sundhar PJ 43 is a chanay native
who went to
iet karag poran later to Stanford and warranted.
If you lower 10 things you may want to know
about Sundar Pichai a one sudder pechay was born in
his father was an electrical engineer with the British firm
called GC 2 BJ was the captain of his high
school cricket team?
It took the team to win the Tamil Nadu regional
cricket tournament 3 he earned his bachelor of engineering degree
from IIT karag port in metallurgical engineering he holds and
MS from Stanford University an MBA from the Wharton school
of the University of Pennsylvania.
For each a work in engineering and product management at
Applied Materials
and in management consulting at McKinsey and company 5 he
joined Google in 2004 he led the product management an
innovation efforts for a suite of Google's client software products.
6 he went out to oversee
the development of
different apps like Gmail and Google Maps 7 pechay added
Android to the Google products 8 he serves as a
member of board
of advisors at hruba ain't.
he has also been the director of jive software pan
he was initially appointed product chief by then CEO Larry
Page on 24 October and finally appointed as CEO of
Google on 10 August 2015.